hi everyone i'm jonathan trunks and
today i got another tactical challenge
for you so let's not mess around let's
get straight to the puzzle alright so
here's your challenge for the day in
this position is black to move so go
ahead and see if you can find the best
move here you can pause your video if
you need a little bit more time but the
solution is Bishop to e4 and white is
powerless against the threat of rook to
h1 but now the real fun begins
in this position its mate in four do you
think you can survive four moves with
white go ahead and pause your video and
see if you can do it okay
the first way to delay the mate is
Bishop to c1 and after rook takes c1
perhaps the most obvious way of delaying
the mate the longest is to play the move
rook to d1 and after you take like Queen
to f1 and now white will get mated very
shortly here what anymore play a
prettier way to achieve the same result
is to start with the move Queen to f1
and now after you take now you play rook
to d1 and alright so you can take either
way you can play rook takes d1 Queen
takes d1 but perhaps the most artistic
and most aesthetically pleasing is to
play instead rook takes F to only move
this King g1 and now Queen takes g3
checkmate
thank you for watching this video
yeah tell me how you did did you were
you able to solve it let me know in the
comments below and go ahead and hit the
subscribe button if you want to see more
content like this thank you for watching
and we'll see you next time for another
tactical challenge